변분 양자 고유값 풀이, 즉 VQE는 초기 하이브리드 양자-고전 알고리즘 중 하나로,
여러 가지 이유에서 흥미로워요. 첫째로, 이 영상에서 살펴보겠지만 특정 유형의 문제에 유망한 접근법이에요. 둘째로,
역사적으로 중요하며 adapt VQE 같은 많은 향상된 알고리즘의 기반을 닦았어요.
마지막으로, VQE는 꽤 단순해요. 이 알고리즘에서 양자 컴퓨터와 고전 컴퓨터가 각각 무엇을 하는지
그리고 어떻게 상호작용하는지 이해하기 쉬워요. VQE 계산에는 네 가지 주요 구성 요소가 있어요.
첫째로, 연산자가 있어요. 흔히 Hamiltonian이라고 하며 H로 표기하는데, 이건 시스템의 어떤 성질을 설명해요.
최적화하려는 성질이죠. 다르게 말하면, 이 연산자의 고유벡터 중에서
최솟값에 해당하는 것을 찾는 거예요. 그 고유벡터를 바닥 상태라고 부르는 경우가 많아요.
다음으로, '접근'을 뜻하는 ansatz가 있어요. 이건 구하려는 고유벡터를 근사하는 양자 상태를 준비하는 quantum circuit이에요.
사실 ansatz는 quantum circuit들의 집합이에요. ansatz 안의 일부 gate들이
매개변수화되어 있거든요. 즉, 변화시킬 수 있는 매개변수를 입력받아요. 이 quantum circuit 집합은
바닥 상태를 근사하는 다양한 양자 상태를 준비할 수 있어요.
다음으로, 추정기가 필요해요. 현재의 변분 양자 상태에서 연산자 H의 기댓값을 추정하는 수단이죠.
때로는 이 기댓값 자체가 우리가 정말로 관심 있는 것이기도 해요. 이걸
비용 함수라고 불러요. 다른 경우에는 하나 이상의 기댓값으로부터 출발해서 쓸 수 있는 더 복잡한 함수를 다루기도 해요.
하나 이상의 기댓값으로부터 출발해서요.
마지막으로, 고전적인 최적화기가 필요해요. 이 비용 함수를 최소화하기 위해 매개변수를 조정하는 알고리즘이에요.
양자가 어떤 역할을 하는지 다루기 전에, 풀고자 하는 문제와 전반적인 접근법을 먼저 정리해 봐요.
과학과 산업에서 중요한 많은 최적화 문제를 행렬값 문제로 표현할 수 있어요. 일반적으로
행렬의 최솟값과 그에 해당하는 고유벡터를 원하죠. 행렬 H는
물리 시스템의 에너지를 기술하는 Hamiltonian일 수 있어요. 최솟값은 바닥 상태 에너지
E0가 되고, 고유벡터는 보통 사이 서브 0으로 표기하는 대응하는 양자 바닥 상태가 돼요.
아니면 행렬이 조합 최적화 문제와 관련된 복잡한 비용 함수를 설명할 수도 있어요.
물류 분야 같은 곳에서요. 그리고 고유 상태 s 서브 opt는
배송 네트워크의 그래프에서 컷을 레이블링하는 이진 문자열 같은 문제의 최적 해가 돼요. 실제로는
물리 과학 밖에서도 Hamiltonian이라는 용어를 모든 관심 행렬에 사용하는 게 일반적이에요.
n행 n열의 행렬 문제가 있다고 해봐요. 이런 문제는 행렬에 대한 어떤 가정도 없이
n이 수백에서 수천 정도일 때 고전적인 풀이로 빠르고 정확하게 풀 수 있어요. 희소
행렬, 즉 대부분의 항이 0인 경우에는 n이 랩톱에서도 수십억까지 가능해요.
하지만 이 숫자를 초과하는 정말 거대한 문제에는 근사적이거나 발견적인 방법이 자주 필요해요.
행렬이 클수록, 그리고 덜 희소할수록 문제는 다루기 어려워지고 더 영리한 기법이 동원돼야 해요. 행렬이 너무 커서
정확한 대각화가 불가능한 경우를 가정해봐요. 더 나아가 문제에 대해 충분히 알아서
목표 상태의 전반적인 구조에 대해 어느 정도 추측이 가능하고, 초기 추측과 유사한 상태들을 탐색하여
비용이나 에너지를 더 낮출 수 있는지 확인하고 싶다고 해봐요. 이게 변분 접근법이고, 고전 컴퓨터로
정확한 대각화가 불가능할 때 사용하는 방법 중 하나예요. 다음과 같이 작동해요.
먼저, 변화시킬 매개변수 theta를 가진 추측 상태를 만들어요.
이 초기 추측이 무작위일 수도 있지만, 그건 권장되지 않아요. 당면한 문제에 대한 지식을 활용해서
추측을 최대한 조정하는 게 좋아요.
둘째로, 그 상태에서의 연산자 기댓값을 계산해요.
셋째로, 변분 매개변수를 변경하고 반복해요.
넷째로, 변분 부분 공간에서 가능한 상태들의 지형에 대해 축적된 정보를 활용해서 점점 더 나은
추측을 하고 목표 상태에 접근해요.
변분 원리는 우리의 변분 상태가 목표 바닥 상태의 고유값보다 낮은 고유값을 산출할 수 없다는 것을 보장해요.
따라서 기댓값이 낮을수록 바닥 상태를 더 잘 근사하는 거예요.
이 접근법에서 각 단계의 난이도에 대해 이야기해봐요.
매개변수를 설정하거나 업데이트하는 건 계산적으로 쉬워요. 어려운 점은 물리적으로 의미 있는 유용한
초기 매개변수를 선택하는 거예요. 이전 반복에서 축적된 정보를 사용해서 바닥 상태에 가까워지도록
매개변수를 업데이트하는 건 쉽지 않아요. 하지만 이걸 꽤 효율적으로 수행하는 고전 최적화 알고리즘이 있어요.
이 고전적인 최적화가 비싼 이유는 단지 많은 반복이 필요할 수 있기 때문이에요.
최악의 경우, 반복 횟수가 n에 대해 지수적으로 늘어날 수 있어요.
계산적으로 가장 비싼 단일 단계는 거의 확실히 주어진 상태에서의 행렬 기댓값이에요.
n×n 행렬이 n 요소 벡터에 작용해야 하는데, 이는 최악의 경우 n 제곱 수준의
곱셈 연산에 해당해요. 이걸 매개변수 반복마다 해야 해요. 극도로
큰 행렬의 경우 계산 비용이 높아요. 이제 이 부분의 계산을
양자 컴퓨터에 맡기는 걸 상상해봐요. 이 기댓값을 계산하는 대신, 변분 ansatz를 사용해서
양자 컴퓨터에서 theta의 상태 s를 준비한 다음 측정을 해서 추정하는 거예요.
그걸 좀 더 살펴봐요. H는 일반적으로 측정하기 쉽지 않아요. 예를 들어, 여러 개의
비가환 Pauli X, Y, Z 연산자들로 구성될 수 있어요.
하지만 H는 각각 쉽게 측정 가능한 항 H 서브 알파의 선형 결합으로 쓸 수 있어요. 예를 들어,
Pauli 연산자나 비트 단위로 교환 가능한 Pauli 연산자 그룹이죠. 상태 S에서
H의 기댓값은 구성 항 H 알파의 기댓값들의 가중 합이에요.